I wanted to show you here the pelvic
floor and now okay okay so this blue
line which extends from the coccyx bone
which is your tailbone all the way I
thought that was the Nike swoosh for a
second I was like man do we have a
lawsuit but no so this is I'm sorry your
this is now back to the conversation how
can you yes this is a penis you say so
yeah I know when you can track this
muscle this is the mate this is the
Kegel muscle of the pelvic floor muscle
oh I see so a lot of that problem is
this starts to weaken that starts to
weaken and then if you can strengthen
that it can help increase rigidity of
the penis during during satisfactory
sexual intercourse it can delay orgasm
so it can enhance it it can actually
increase the intensity of organism so I
want to teach you how to do it okay okay
all right
first I want you to just to visualize
your mind if what what a Keagle would be
is if you were to start to contract your
muscles to stop urination like if you
were to take a walk in the bathroom so
squeeze I do that all the time diving
back one more second I sure I I
constantly when I'm like in the snow I
stop if I'm making a word you know and
then yeah I'm constantly writing long
essays yeah you just we all every guy
knows that feeling of like stop
urinating and then start again yeah okay
so wait and if you were to sit for those
that don't know that feeling if you were
to stand in front of the mirror and
naked pull the base of your piece like
imagine to pull the base of the penis in
the top yeah so in up squeeze wait what
I was holed up Enid you're in front of
the mirror what's that and you pull in
pull it in this top note with your hand
now oh it's like where are we pulling it
- where is it going pull it inside tuck
it up and in with the penis up with the
scrotum squeeze okay in with the penis
up with the scrotum squeeze your yet I'm
just loving that poem where does where
does haiku I've ever heard you have a
device for people that will help them is
that right I do all right what's this
well the cool thing about this this is a
device that's designed for men okay to
enhance Kegel strength this is called
the Kegel boost for men and you sit on
remember that area I showed you the
balloon Nike yeah sure well you sit that
area between your testicles and your
coccyx bone change
[Applause]
Jenny not all of us have been to medical
school all right you and your
high-flying jargon so what would I do
here on this you want me to sit on that
on that area
[Applause]
this stays off your clothes with my
clothes on okay all right and I thought
someone wanted to do it right okay what
do I do I sit here are you positioning
me wedding ring goes over here
love you baby all right do what you
gotta do
sit here am I in the right spot I don't
know if I'm completely okay no I don't
think so they'll you miss I'm getting no
status what do you put your fingers in
there doctor a miniskirt squeeze your
feet
[Applause]
I'm not doing anything give a [ __ ] about
any of that uh pin and squeeze I'm just
sitting here and enjoying the ride
fantastic thank you what are we doing
now okay alright so in up and then out
right and then is this something you can
carry with you don't take it to work you
can sit on it you can do it anywhere
we're sitting on the subway bottle like
that yeah this is me on the bus here in
LA that's the female one see you have it
lucky oh my god okay this goes in
okay so fortunately you don't have to
put anything in you didn't have to sit
okay and see and women will squeeze
around that see that's how we squeeze
and the good news is you can just wear
this creepy right now
ah
you